Carpal tunnel tendonitis rheumatoid arthritis osteoarthritis arthritis
Is there a permanent solution? I've been taking and and making herbal tinctures tea soaking in musty baths
Make easy of oil using castor oil compresses just started so far have felt better
So when a person mentions multiple different
Syndrome's Carpal tunnel tendonitis rheumatoid arthritis osteoarthritis arthritis
All those are different things that can have different ideologies
So yeah, they're all inflammatory
So maybe the common
You know disorder is increase inflammation and you really need to get get down to inflammation or better yet find out why
You have an increased systemic inflammation
But if it's mainly arthritis, you know with joint issues obviously most of these are joint issues Carpal tunnel is
A joint but is is more so attempted issue and a muscular issue with the brachial radialis muscle on your forearm
So Carpal tunnel patients have issues with their forearm lots of times they have
spasms or
You know
Swelled in the brachial radialis either due to excess use
Common data is using your muscle day on a computer you can get Carpal tunnel issues or
Type in all day you can get Carpal tunnel issues because you're using those extensor muscles of your forearm
So working those out stripping those out
Working on origin insertion points on those muscles can be very helpful if you find it you can go to a
Physical therapist or a car parther does kinesiology applied kinesiology they can best help you with Carpal tunnel
Tendeditis depends on what tendon is involved tendonitis is inflammation of a tendon
It's usually due to an injury
So if there's an injury that tendon can be you know partially pulled away from the bone and pushing it back on the bone physically
It's again doing physical origin insertion work can be extremely helpful
Again find a chiropractor that your path or
Physical therapist who does applied kinesiology
rheumatoid arthritis is completely different than osteoarthritis so osteoarthritis is a degenerative arthritis
So by hurt my knee played football in college and now I'm 45 years old and I'm starting to have a lot of knee pain
At that spot
It's because of wear and tear. It's because of abdominal biodynamics biophysics of that joint
Because of an old injury so osteoarthritis is the same thing as degenerative joint disease
degenerative disc disease in the spine that is
degenerative arthritis
It's not inflammatory base it might have inflammatory components maybe there's inflammation
At that injury, but it's not caused from inflammation. It's caused from degeneration
rheumatoid arthritis
psoriatic arthritis those are
Those are autoimmune conditions. So for person does have a diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis and they have elevated RA factor
Um, that's a totally different ballgame. So that's not a degenerative disease. That's not caused from
ill use of your hands or something over time
Just because you they have you know been in a profession where you used your hands and overused your hands
That will not cause you that there will not be a precursor to an autoimmune type arthritis
So the arthritis that are autoimmune based totally different Bolognax
You really need to jump on our
Product disease at autoimmune course and start learning about how to deal with autoimmune disease
Because you have antibodies against those joint capsules. It's destroyed that joint you're going to have
You know, there's three different phases of autoimmune disease. You need to learn about that
There's a lot of things you need to figure out what the triggers are and such
um to help calm that down. So
So is there the question was is there a permanent solution? Well, it really depends on what we're talking about
Usually with carpal tunnel and a tendonitis. Yes, there's a permanent solution
You could heal that with the degenerative arthritis not so much a permanent solution
It's about management
It's about increasing the joint fluid in the joint capsule. It's you know, there's a lot of different management techniques for a degenerative arthritis
With an autoimmune condition with an autoimmune arthritis
It's not a cure either. There's it's management, but it's a totally different form of management with an autoimmune disease
So get on our chronic disease at autoimmune course. It's exactly
Why I created that course so you can understand
What an autoimmune disease is how to deal with it and how to deal with the triggers that could go along with autoimmune disease